I just think we should just keep this
thing as honest as [__] possible like
what did you reckon when you first see
me video write a message to nail Ranger
yeah Newcastle United play on pond life
would probably be a better [__] term
for the little [__] I think my cousin's
increased on YouTube yes to see ours
that can't be arsed artist camp yeah but
all these daughters brought shame on our
club getting arrested posting pictures
himself on in there holding guns and I'm
feeling it like frustrated even listenin
to you like why the [__] called this guy
just get up on time and go to work like
you're lucky to do what you do Hardman
it's not easy and every time I get a
chance and do you all start doing laughs
that's a fetus perhaps it's your
stupidity man and I don't mean no no
couldn't you wait for I think it is yeah
I think you've got a [__] good life
ahead of you
you could still flip and turn around I
still don't know if you're like ready
buddy a message to nail rain ha welcome
to the true Geordie broadcast message as
me like active yeah I just think we
should just keep this like as honest as
[__] possible like what did you write
them when you first see me video
obviously the fans went mad and I
thinking
listen Mac I knew that obviously it
wasn't my place to say anything well it
kind of was because I knew that I was
there for a while I think I was pissed
with not playing for a little while at
par do you bench me you made me train
with the kids for a while I was that was
great polish is that what's going on
there I'm watching with the kids like
half my size it's not making no sense
obviously had three years there then
eventually I got back into the squat I
was on the bench of killers against it
could have been Evan common but I'm
gonna game anyway I've come out and said
blah blah blah ooh I had to run onto it
and enough I think my cousin's is this
boot had this wood headed guy going
crazy and on YouTube you have to see
how's that I can't be arsed I just can't
be out but then I just saw now you need
to see it because the views on the sky
mad land and I see comments on Twitter
like I knew and me and then obviously I
see and I was like
know what I meant I said to you what at
the time I was just pissed off with a
lovely plane and obviously footballs all
I know all right so you're this is kind
of cool for me because I think full
circle this is where it all started me
talking about you and now me life's
[__] change your life changes for
networks you give me a text last week
say give me a ring yeah and like you're
really struggling to get back in the
game or to a position where you know you
wanna listen I'm struggling it's just
put out there I'm struggling but
obviously it is what I'm used to you cuz
I said I think it's that it happened at
such a young age for me where things are
happening Newcastle I'm paying in a
Premier League I'm like wow this is like
a dream come true this is what I prayed
for like this is who I need that and
it's happening but I think it come too
fast and then I started bringing so much
people with me along with me Romans
people weren't good for me but you just
never know your friends are and then
basically I felt like I was getting
dragged down but at the time I'm trying
to show my people good things you know I
mean but yeah it was it's hard when it
was tough but when nobody really will
touch you now is that the problem close
to it yeah because of my talent and my
ability I believe in my believe there's
still there's still options there but
it's basically pistachio not something
I'm getting offered to be honest man
yeah but that's just that's just how it
goes you know I mean I self-inflicted
and I can't believe no about myself
cause it's self-inflicted so you said on
the phone
people are saying come and train with us
awesome it was that kind of decent Club
say come and chamber it's hard because
I've been on trial before and I've
gotten to Blackpool and they messed me
up big start that's where not that's an
image really done I started getting into
crazy things and doing dumb stuff ended
up getting a cool case that you know I
mean so I don't go down a road on trial
people know I can do and they know my
talent is just about you know think that
like clubs are saying the reason they're
saying come at rain is because you're
[__] notorious at this point I know
what you know one who leaves what you're
saying you've you haven't had the second
chance you've had a tenth chance so
there are 15 yeah all of us if you if
you book although and improve you salt
and then you can it's not over 27 but
I'm getting old I'm not spring chicken
no more so it's like you're not
potential anymore I've got a [__] do
that but obviously I know my I believe
in my ability I can do it's just I've
got a cut off a lot of people are
focused on myself tunnel vision and I've
got I just make it work coz there's
youngsters coming up and getting England
called all sorts that you know I mean
and they're telling it so they're not
gonna really take a chance or not all
boy what caused his trouble what in the
past because I'm not that anymore about
yeah you know I mean I've been sacked
from like four clubs it's ridiculous
like why are you gonna give me a chance
but I know that's what it is about for
me though it's like you you want to tell
your side of the stories of course of
course I've got I've got sent off
[__] practically like a rap sheet
about you I like one of the guys who
works with us and I want to [__] like
go through some of this [__] with you
know migrant it feels like there's so
much to you it's insane me yeah it's
ridiculous
I'll be honest if I was the manager or
chairman I wouldn't really mess with now
or in general but I believe in myself
and I know my ability and what I can do
so I'm deaf you gonna get another chance
just about taking well you know despite
what I said in the past yeah you [__]
they do have ability hmm and you showed
it you've showed it to them soon but
there's always a problem it that's
that's that's what I'm trying to matter
what the [__] by the Masters not venture
too often I think yes well you started
it right though you used to go to church
and I stopped it cuz to play football
what I play football but obviously it
was Sunday mornings and evenings they
just got it was that it was just a there
was no time for football hours out okay
I love football when can actually kick a
ball out I'm in church like everything
every single Sunday even sometimes on a
midweek you know
meanwhile in it I got signed by Crystal
Palace and I think and then he started
to kick you from there to be fair I'm
looking through here you know you you
ended up and having your own flat when
your Southampton to keep you away from
all the troubles in what was going on as
in a lot Southampton were a lot of a few
players and then I was just causing
havoc that I was a sneaking out at night
time a few days I'm not gonna say the
names because I don't want to drag them
into [__] but a few pairs of sneakers
sneaking us out all the players were
sneaking us out a lot I never see there
was the goody two-shoes and there was me
and there was a few others but I was
sneak out go out by the woman what we do
want your outdoor what went pop better
even and and obviously our drinking
birds are there let and I'll sneak back
into the lodge but sneaking back in was
difficult because we have to climb up
some some type of wood that wooden
ladder it was crazy and then obviously
the woman would live there she went back
to the corset now all sneaking out
there's a blah blah blah so that kind of
messed me up but that's never happened
in history of this the Southampton Lord
someone getting their own flat you know
I mean I was only a scholar as always
even a pro and they gave me a flat
because they were too I reckon they
would give me a problem in what I'm
seeing throughout all of this when I
wrote it earlier was like special
treatment you you got special treatment
a lot like people seen a lot in you know
price and that was that like the worst
thing that could have happened
possibly yeah definitely like not you
know I was speaking about that the other
day it's just true that do you go I
wouldn't say special yeah I did gift I
would say that yeah I'll be honest I
think I did to a certain extent but then
when when it come down to the crunch
time and that my mom or my parents I
would get beat so ever I would
definitely get the beat he got to stage
I was laughing at the beat spot
I did get special treatment definitely I
was the only child for ages so alright
so your careers just starting to take
off yeah your parents you mentioned them
what what was your relationship like
with them grow not not me and my mum
that my mom she's in fact my mom I don't
know where you're at enough to
so I love my mum to bits and she's
actually guided me and helped me in a
lot of ways but at the time I wasn't
really taken in because my dad was
around but I wasn't my mum played that
is all you know I mean it was on an M
things but it was a yeah well it wasn't
I wouldn't say my dad wasn't with a try
it but I was more like yes I have a lot
of brothers and sisters so it was it's
not easy for him but my mom she
definitely mom and that our relationship
was good cousins good when you're doing
these stupid things or not not most
people alright at this point have a have
a voice in their mind that goes don't do
that and if you're gonna [__] it up
there you don't have that voice by the
sounds of it all I didn't at least maybe
it's taken a long time to get that yes
if taken a long time to just take in but
at the time young a reckless or I was
just like I don't know this is my life
I'm gonna do this forever I have fun I'm
living I'm making money but at that
stage when they put me in that stuff up
then I was only making that if I plan to
eat right so but still other people
around you you like your friends from
back home yeah are you the man now like
you yeah big time - people say oh he's
gonna make it he's gonna do well it's
what stage he is talking about
Southampton yeah cuz I seemed a lot of
hangers-on like definitely but obviously
I did have my day ones with me always
warned along the journey you know I mean
I still up to now but there was a lot of
leeches but that soon we'll get to that
when we talk about Newcastle at
Southampton obviously our scoring goals
I had a little spell in jail and I was
16 because I had a case before it says
yeah 11 weeks in AU offenders yes ma'am
a parole and armed robbery
yeah what you couldn't watch this this
is the disc when I was growing up I'm
just a soul eyes to see you're a breeze
whatever mm-hmm like I said I wasn't but
I wasn't born with a silver spoon at the
mouth but I wanted a little extra bits
okay yeah so I started taking people's
phones doing all the madness that and
I've seen people were always in me doing
the same thing it wasn't right obviously
not but it's a good career path you
could have heard it up
so you weren't like not at the age of 15
you don't really know what's gonna
happen like yeah you could have for good
but a lot of people get told and get no
way so it was like I was in two minds
and I was going to run for semi-pro
Crystal Palace released me there are so
much things going on that I went to a
BTech College who protec him Barney no
softly and then from there I was doing
my robberies now and again here and
there not to talk of a few more people
did you enjoy that
no you got a positive getting selling
the item yeah but I felt terrible at the
time like the victim at night you know I
mean this DC part working hard for their
money their mobile phones and all things
like that but when I wasn't thinking
about it or not at the time I was in two
minds to be fair like after Daniel for
life some somebody's Bravo somebody you
know I mean and anyone will get just
boy/girl everyone will get it doesn't
matter as long as we get the phone and
we get them one so we targeting places
oh you just literally going up with a
gun and no there wasn't no no at a time
there was no gun or nothing like that
nothing like that it was just silly
stupid childish robberies just taking
people saw Nitschke that are whoops
remember is that bluetooth that there's
Walkman phones yeah yeah I know was that
what some of you got and then the phone
he's that person's phone will go missing
once Allah but I gave you my phone and
did they cool it a Jimmy they could a
general from me adrenals
so that's how it really made my man you
mean when at that age but then going on
check I went to my mom said listen you
can't keep getting cool cases I know
this and live in this house it's not
gonna happen so I said you know I figure
I'll and it's called this these times
I've got that the five robberies case
are going because we were you want me to
talk about oh yeah yeah you [__] talk
about anything miserable a few of my
people we went on a late night I
remember and then this is when you're
like something you know so now this is
on 15 and then went on the robberies if
you disrupt everyone we saw on the road
literally anyone will get a woman which
is mad to say in her house he of you
about six of us and all of my classes I
saw sort of and now I was at Aulis at
the time I was tall for me
where what position would you say you
took in the group were you like a
ringleader or were you one of the guys
who had a presence but I wasn't sounds
the ringleader bottom of Prisons was
felt oh yeah people are gonna be [__]
[__] right and if there's like 60 you
lads and you're especially a real big
lad like you is in there
a woman's gonna [__] [__] yourself
like that no it's okay you know like
these like that woman for example and
I'm not trying to get all preachy on you
you clearly thought about this what like
even to this day like you've moved on
yeah I know I like she will [__]
remember this could be my karma you know
I'm saying you know this could be harm
or cause things to not walk down the
street now without [__] they can
remember that time when it's crazy I
thought I felt terrible like like I
remember saying that to my people not
know women that no elderly people or
nothing but when there's out some people
that you might get jealous of someone
getting something anything I'm getting
the next thing like that's what happened
from there it's we are now that no women
that don't touch the women that is crazy
but like I see when you're young and
reckless you just grab anything and
obviously we've what's the motivation
just having nothing just having nothing
and wanting [__] do you think there's
not what these lads are like I think so
and I think it's like a gets the stage
where everyone sees things anything yeah
that's cool but it's very inconvenient
another after another than CID
undercover police comes rushing past us
I think one of my people had a knife and
that's why the Citiz aren't but no one
used the knife they said is armed we
could he ran back put everything in a
bush and then we carried on walking back
in that normal it's a few run away and
if you go away but a few yeah a few of
us made most of our state and we
obviously the police come out stopped us
where were we
blah blah blah and then they looked in a
bush they found whoever they have think
they had to someone in the van
go past and say yeah these are the guys
were done eating right so that's what we
were arrested was in his cells for like
three days maybe and an the what you
call what you think them when you're
there though because you're young and
I've had I've got like two cases already
pending like little things that little
dumb things I'm just good even as big as
you were you're still [__] you know
easy work for these guys the proper guys
I'm am and our bureau up in jail twice
now and I can't do Joe I don't like Joe
I can hold my own but I don't like the
bang up like 23 hours in a day doing
nothing eating for getting canteen
bollocks like you're sitting on your ass
and if round there's people in there
saying it seems like I want this I want
that sure I'm there like broth just go
get a job or do you sort of that but
like I say when you go out you get more
wise there's people in there thinking
about their next plot and what they're
doing to get my education so criminal
will that criminal straightaway there's
people doing that but if that's the
hustle then that's what they do in it
that's how they get that's the only way
they know I had to meet money know
everyone's got a brain know everyone's
got talent so that's how people do their
thing so it's kind of interesting to you
because actually the fact that you are a
footballing you a bit of a famous face
sort of kept you from going down that
route because you can't be robbing
people who were going that's now arrange
a obviously the money stack up we'll get
to that
yeah I was in the cell for like three
days and then eventually got to call cuz
I think it wasn't a Friday so yet
there's no courts on the weekend so yeah
to wait till Monday
we went on Monday Monday come obviously
we got bail but I had a tag no no I
didn't get at I got a curfew seven to
nine and then got home my mom sat me
down I said listen that's it this is the
last thing or you can just call you
somewhere else on the road we have you
know call your guy I'm taking sure into
the South Gate College it's a protic B
Tech football thing scouts core quad it
went into your pissed off at into should
I remember that she which you want to
slap me and interview because you got to
do like a little interview before you
gotta get into the college before you
enter the team so I have a little
interview so that could have messed up
from
she was AIT was stinking a [__]
literally loud this data alone AVL's
[__] you know even looking at a woman
right now occur and she's just my mom
basically pinched me and I said cool
anyway got in long social but in wait
you got a [__] trip on your shoulder
yeah then she I was pissed I did I just
didn't want to do the whole education
education that's it I didn't want to do
it I just wasn't on it I wasn't on Yahoo
and then eventually I was like you know
I'm gonna do this I'm gonna do it on a
track we work hard because they're
catching cases and do know that it's
long now this is You Got Talent try use
it so I've gone on the child the first
day I remember had a soul and ankle
strap man Kona we are trained for the
first day and then there was a trial and
he said yeah you're in litchi go in
there after the first 40 minutes got in
there not make sure ya know as I
remember telling my mom I'm definite and
in this light out the confidence was
higher so I'm definitely gonna get into
this team at whatever blah blah blah
anyway now we have a team we have a game
and we train for a few weeks you had
getting fit preseason we have a game
against Southampton traveled up there I
remember sitting literally there was no
seats whom you had to see on actual like
a back like she would wait Southampton
I was on the bench - was using - no and
then I come on off the bench I got a
half and I'm not scoring two goals one
with my left for which I used just to
stand on little I'm just a metaphor and
what I think was a head I didn't after
I've gone back down and to London and
they call she said yes Southampton I
interested in - I was like I must be me
I scored two goals today he was seeing
me and he pulled me aside and we got
back and said yeah Southampton want you
borough I also start so basically
Southampton wanted me to go on not even
go on char they wanted to sign me so I
didn't even get to start for the protec
team their season had gone straight to
Southampton then I was that wait hold on
Southampton what we saw last it she
changing right now that house thinking
wow okay not basically no work when this
you just walked straight and straight in
Bay City I didn't even stock in mud that
seat there season for the protec team
and you had to pay like 400 pan to get
the topper
see and the Kiowa and thousands part
that was part of how you went down and I
love how yeah and I remember my mom said
what you ain't started the season season
for them so technically I can get my
money back yeah how's that so your money
back there was a bit of drama with that
but she got her money back I think the
guy was moaning I think his name was
Pete
he was morning saying well we helped you
get this lava which is true but my much
times are hardened it wanting someone
about you know I mean so she got our
money back eventually they asked for the
taxi back because they just being a bit
off gave it back to them and then yeah
started at Southampton and then from
there I still had the case so I didn't
say nothing to Southampton cuz I thought
a roomie because we'll just as soon as I
got there so I didn't mention it but
long story short starts going also there
everything's going well and let her
conscious of it as solicitors
Southampton Lord John's there but she
she says solicitors on the letter so
she's been nosy I remembered a woman's
name but anyway she's a she's opened a
letter without my permission obviously
then the coach like during the season
said to me now have you got anything you
want to say to him he's pulled me aside
and I'm thinking what's this what's this
about know and I'm scoring so much cause
I'm thinking is he gonna say you're in
the bench for the first team or involved
he's that are you sure I said are me
what's this guy and what's going on here
that I was confused so I said to Mum
know what's up he said nothing to do a
police then I knew from that like I was
game all of us I said ah
Dave I'm reasoning with Dave Hockaday I
said to him Dave that I didn't I didn't
know what to say I felt like I couldn't
really say anything on it because I
didn't want to ruin my chance here I'm
I'm doing well for myself I've got
myself out at the area the nori area I
mean pleased that I just wanted to sue
myself I you know I mean I knew was that
listen like I think that's the best
thing I could have done because is that
are you crazy like will back you to the
end you should have told us from the
after the I said how'd you find out and
he said obviously the woman at the lodge
originally from solicitors so from there
carried on playing scoring goals still
still scoring goals
then my court case come up and then our
members all of us in the dock and we're
sitting there that are well now I like
we're thinking we're gonna get bail a
lot of people have been picked out so
we've there my sister said to me you can
have a plea bargain where you just pick
two one robbery and then they'll serve
you on that you get sentence on that so
I said a cool no problem list do a plea
bargain I said yeah that was me they
have on the one robbery and then we've
we've left confirmed for I think
McDonald's breakfast was early but my
Bailey I just thought anxious hours that
nah eat something all right about today
and in my cousin was the first she was a
yeah remanded to custody and remember
things are going well for me now so I've
got a letter from Southampton I've got
so much good references this judge still
said no Vermonters custody are sweaty I
listen a man I'm a man
yeah but I definitely started crying
down there that's my first time John
based like a babies don't 16 I'll
started crying
I was that - my husband was okay we're
going to Jolla actually going to prison
is that to me cuz [__] it that Israel
isn't it we we done the crime after
serve the time he's head is just you
know I mean he's strong mind all day you
crazy
that fingers again wolf me Southampton
no way I can't be going to prison anyway
long sir sure I went to done 11 weeks in
there three weeks in hunter come no
three weeks in forum started playing
with the foot black I got used to it
started playing football with the with
the other people in jail I was it was
crazy and then I remember with beat
teams and then they'll be like at least
I'm dying home to check my woman tonight
blah blah blah you're going back in
there said army I only got a couple of
weeks left over but these times I'd like
nine weeks that I know you know what was
it like when you're in prison or like
because in ended after the tears left
you and you were like alright I'm gonna
do this like what was that first time
like can you remember
I just after the first day the priest
come to see me I was that was that
listen how long can you sit with me for
because I can't be in this cell single
bang up like you're in the cell by
yourself lychee and I remember they
brought a care package that night I got
in there like also Dre and
in the mirror scratched out like it's
not just not the way you want to live
like you know I mean for the next two
months or so pretty much and I knew this
is wrong I'm really in jail
no matter what if it's you've offended
like I'm in jealous of youth offenders
it doesn't matter
jealous Joe he's still gonna be looked
at 24 hours a day but it was terrible
and especially when you're young you got
other people thinking it bad and tough
and they want to prove a point and all
of that so I think the younger
generation Joe when you go Joe a young
age is worse than the more
confrontational yeah they're more likely
I'm the man here well stay like some
stare-off lackeys there's some
competition but I from early I knew
listen read my tan go home get things
done right so but I've done it do you
think playing football you can sort of
em people's respect by being good other
people see you in there like always
actually alright yeah definitely like a
few other cops in there at the time when
I was young with that this guy
definitely papers that I he's got
something nice playing with D that they
let me play with the older look like
they said yeah come he's playing for us
and I'm not screwing like five goals in
the game the Lots people like disguise
some forecasted why even in it why even
in their way you know I said bro play
for Southampton but there's something
old it's always off according me like
with the last the new recent time
Suffolk all the name popped up but yeah
ketchup ketchup ketchup much always
behind you get out go out Southampton
yeah two things yeah yeah yeah obviously
and a strike partner and I think he
happy I saw the jelly seen his face when
I come on out wisely out of that bars
that nah I'm not ready to work but I was
banned from the lunch so this is we're
getting across that so what I do now she
said are you can eat here but you can't
stay here but I'm not one person in a
lodge in history analyst facts Gareth
Bill's been in that long happy all
caught feel caught
Leon bet there's been so much players in
that thing but knowing that history
McGorgeous
I don't know if you had at my gorget no
place for each suite okay yeah but there
are so much sniffing their bread really
is so much cheaper but there was no one
woke up been furloughed so they actually
set me up to go to
my own flat so I mom said okay I'll do
that no problem the academy director
come to see me was enjoy I said this
we're gonna put you in your own flat you
know standard a lot you can eat there
you gotta get there in the morning for
your take get on the bus to training
block no problem so I was doing that for
a while my mom was up there she stopped
working and she basically worked from
home because she she had my grant on the
children's home so she was working from
home was her effort but it was still
like around my mom's putting all this
effort like and I'm seeing I'm difficult
make you work anyway on the on the last
day I think the last week was breaking
up summer for the summer
I remember stealing so much kit to bring
back to my friends and everything that I
stole everyone's boots first team boots
and then don't like how this happened
anyway now and you know I even took all
the flour my I would I don't know I
think I just wanted to just bring back
to my friends and show them kits and
boots and I don't know maybe even on the
court there it wasn't to talk about why
you were released or whatever yeah it
says he stole so much kit like we don't
even mind a few pairs in which you took
the [__] everything what's what's
confusing to me at this point is maybe
it's retrospect various hindsight you're
thinking of other people when you're
stealing for these people
yeah see yeah yeah it's not what's the
thought you like aren't gonna see these
people again so I'm gonna not I think
you the first team are probably gonna
get new boots regardless it's the last
they don't get new boots don't new boots
I thought let me and we're gonna change
every season you change kit lad their
finger so I said this is all they to be
fair south on turned the staff said you
can take a few bits home but I just went
the extra mile and took everything name
[Music]
you know Lily look enough to sell cars
bill the paper and you know I took the
piss by taking a woman's roses you know
chocolate roses I think she put that in
the bag as I said yeah and then I hid my
stuff in a bush I've gone mad what is it
about the bush so I'll put yours in
their pocket why not
you'd love living in this no it's great
yeah believe this like you had a good
thing going and and they let you go I
mean to be fair they say in the case
they're seen the fact that you can't be
trusted and live with the rest of the
guys then that's like the third strike
then isn't it really in there yeah
that's it like that's it so the next day
I've gone to look for my stuff mmm
they're not there so I'm thinking
[Music]
perfectly I put something there to know
where to ball back to you ever anyway
they've they've pulled me aside and said
we need to talk to you
nothing can what's going on right I've
even got mad at another player because I
thought he saw me hide my stuff's on
that property right and [__] like crazy
doing a fight that and his that brought
swear I didn't take nothing I mean
nothing
he left the trail of breadcrumbs
remember sweetie I remember I remember
his name was Kay McLaggen our members
mark Idol who was close and it was that
was like do you take my [__] [__] you
and he was the first person to be able
to get a license on cars I want to
scratch a car when I did it but I wasn't
him it was the kid man what saw me on
the camera put a put last
stash of the things I'd love to have
that yeah I remember me anyway like so a
week they said they're gonna get back to
me they said I'm suspended until further
notice
I've gone to me in the managers there I
think it was an Nigel person Nigel
person what's the other one George
Burley us a great Jeff chick cranberry
yeah it's too far back but one of them
out of all of them Nigel Pearson's the
last man you on the cut you may say so
right miserable [__] when he was in
that meeting I was like shaking [__]
myself is that goddamn Clara vote you
like this I was that
how did the fire what did you say if
you'd said like you now take a look I've
got nothing I'm just trying to [__]
like I was just did you say I don't
think that would have worked
I don't think no a car literally I'll be
lying if I remember I said remember we
had this mean and all scared of scared
our master our soul skip then I was that
had the meeting then I went back to my
agent just like she did my anxiety just
went through the roof the whole journey
because I who do you think right they're
gonna get rid of me I remembered my
agents couldn't eat group really what do
you think Nick PowerBlock and he was
that I don't know we have to wait and
see
anyway got home not the phone this is
we're gonna phone you phoned comma and
Bluetooth hands-free oh yeah we're gonna
terminate is still blah blah blah that
and I remember my friend being in the
back insane so what's he about see we
were going back to now robberies
literally because he was with me for the
whole studies already who is that -
what's it back to you robberies about
that bro I can't deal look I suppose I'm
not going back to that forget that
anyway my you said guys could have this
situation it could have been handled
very differently and potentially I know
people are look at this now and to some
people
we've got no sympathy for you yeah
definitely yes and from a council
estates are kinda I know allowed to wear
a mime it had so much [__] talent and
just blew it right yes I've seen this
before and I feel like if the situation
had been handled differently your whole
life could have been different potential
Arkansas as I say people around me that
is it was hard but you have to just cut
them off for yourself it's not like
you're saying I'm cutting them off
because [__] you is that I'm cutting you
off because I got when I'm finished my
career can I come to you and say yeah
you pay my rent this month are you know
you got a do you serve you got a tunnel
vision and so it's laugh you
but Swindon not long after Symington yes
in deny someone Hyundai because under
North I really know Dana and so how do
you end up with Swindon and our members
I think a common belief on tour hi went
along what my agent said swim them when
you're set off [__] you know syndrome
I'm 16 so I'm thinking if you go there
do oh you get a move anyway now I've
gone there I didn't like it at the start
didn't like it I mean my stuff getting
the change rooms I saw touch shocked and
I was like literally like like so hunt
and you come from a good club though I'm
from the best academy in breath and I
was a championship at the time Hampton
still amazing clip still amazing exactly
so tele2 and nurses that I know Lana
smash you bought some life for why I'm
here Baba that's you know what the lads
are decent I'm not gonna judge afro
shade on it I'm just gonna work harder
and get a move hopefully and you know I
done well-paid couple reserved games
down well for myself I remember my
eighth I scored an overhead kick in one
the reserve games and then my agent said
this called burger king went burger king
that what's up but I remember before
that my chain got robbed to so much
things got robbed at that camera again
that all thing got stolen and changing
so swindon owed me some money for that I
remember I could yesterday they didn't
want to pay anyway satvinder your mom
feels lucky she's she's so I know
so gotten to my agent in Burger King sat
down he said listen you're going to new
costs and I was that no I'm happy here I
wanna do I want to get a contract here I
remember they offered me that three
hundred pound a week that I was that
well that because member I didn't even
get to get the price I fountain so I was
used to the 95 I was I 300 panic yeah
let's do it a scoring all new course on
you you're leaving tomorrow how we're
gonna do it is we're gonna leave your
study you're gonna drop your stuff off
before China and we're gonna head out to
Newcastle so that I don't want to do it
anyway the next day comes out didn't do
it
Dennis Wise has got on the phone listen
I you fight are you a maniac you don't
want to come to New : give it a go
then I remember looking at I was living
with Sean Morris in that card if now and
I can't remember the obvious track his
name but yeah I was that would you think
she wanted me that to me she called for
it wrong and I told someone sausage sir
what was like what was like the question
here why do you not want to go no no I
just knew cause I was father I just
thought I wasn't only that I suppose
didn't want to do I'm from London that's
not too fast and it wasn't but Newcastle
were Premier Li cool exactly and you're
Lee to club well you're not even getting
the first team in a sticky French pound
a week I'm sick I've met new friends I'm
comfortable now so it's starting again
is long you know I mean anyway I did
that now I went there no no I was on the
follow that not only anyway I went this
hit drop off the kid I did that the day
off following the after jumped in a car
headed up to Newcastle Wow
and then I remember should we trained
our chain for one day and then I think
asked a few weeks later we had a game a
little preseason game Kevin Keegan was
watching Keegan was a manager at a time
we've like I had a beard man McGuirk
and there was like this guy's got talent
that I think Michael Owen was there a
few other seniors watch the game anyway
long story short they signed me got a
contract 750 a week so that 750 week and
20 grand signing fee so 10 grand 10
grand X I'm not all my days I can buy
the most trainers I want the tracks
everything I want in life right now huge
purchase you can buy a massive Bush 17
so I'm dead
wow this is this is actually happening
last on a two-year deal for Newcastle
and I remember went back to London now
after that I was Boston I was there when
it's gonna come on Sky Sports my name in
the right and when he's gonna come I'm
filming on my on my phone that when's it
gonna come then eventually can't film
the buzzing then went back up to
Newcastle they put me in a lot but I
remember that game I played um I made
friends with one a reserve team plays
like two years older than me maybe
called Frank Danko and he got released
shortly after but became close friends
but I remember I was talking to me is
that yeah
Keegan was because the he had a game he
was involved with the first team so he
was that yeah there's this black boy of
plats that kegels talking black boy of
Platts and a goatee flat what a player
I'm definitely having involved very soon
by Rob Reiner and he's come and told me
that Santino Wow
seriously Frank I'm just saying like I
mean if if I was if I played a game and
Kevin Keegan Michael Owen people are
watching them but those guys go yeah no
I was like I wasn't taking in Lau's that
I just doesn't take him in I was just
doing what I had to do like yeah and I
was shocked that
how am I playing so well with these
players from Newcastle Premier League
and I was doing well I imagine just some
question Kevin Keegan being like he's
good
by the way how'd you have gold teeth at
this point like no I'm not seeing these
signs a million miles away like him it
weighs just keep getting this money from
Peugeot team I know it's mad I had to
add this it was 150 dissing 1 to 150
right I'll just following trend as usual
and you know I mean that looks alright
let me just get yeah follow ancient
Hanako Thank You Jess yeah I've had it
for years so yeah so when
Keegan saw me he eventually got me
involved with the Scots for one time out
there's two ends what's the new cost of
training ground light been been enough
and it is no two ends Academy side and
first team side and reserves and so I
remember coming into training and if the
Academy says ready for training I'm
going to change you then I think he
named Richard Richard he went Luton as a
manager for the Richard II was the
Academy Director boot had [__] old man
army anyway now Richard something he's
come to me and said no island Thompson
do you know Alan Thompson sorry he's
come to me and said I range commonly
suits you yeah I said what's up he said
to me yeah you need to pack your stuff
you're involved with the first-team
squad and traveling with them are that
what he said yeah there's a few injuries
you're traveling awesome yeah knows our
Arsenal get hotter
come back to London as I did she
couldn't even I didn't know what to do
faint what jump off
that for joy what daddy so now I'm up
corny and I couldn't hold the ESET
dissing yeah cool
no problem I've gone back into the
changes that buff to one often I am
involved against awesome do we can you
know that did and then he's gonna told
that person in the whole change in his
budget for me now yeah well hope so I
hope they'll buzzing at the time and you
have travel I've gonna walked across the
side then I've made keygen but I've gone
to him cuz I wasn't I was so young I
didn't know what that I didn't know
about GAF are you - how's that oh you're
at Keegan and then he started literally
laughing for about five minutes straight
him and keep them at laughing creasing
right floor nearly how's that all she
ever done wrong here that and is that no
listen you never call me that again
it's gaffer from now yeah I'm your guy
for your manager I'm the manager this
table
it's CAF are not Keegan but he knew was
wrong he knew our also I didn't really
know yeah child yeah you know I mean
okay
yeah basic F key I said you had Keegan
that and he doesn't thin they're not for
ages so now I'm eventually going to the
squad remember being in a hotel we have
to go to a hotel in London somewhere
shove it down but details on looking at
Mike low in that and all these big
players that I'm here Nicky bar do you
feel like you're just pretending I was I
still know what to do because I remember
I think figures
Nicky boy and Mike low in that there was
a suitcase who's coming around then at
the time they were betting they were lat
oh I bet my case comes first by me now
that Michael
things I how's that cuz you we've not a
spot it was but like that yeah I was
looking at on suitcases mate can you
imagine actually you know I just go in
five of mine comes out first look at
that
that's my and I was this day like wow
you don't know did that you like that's
crazy a huge case comes up with anyway
now you've got this case comes over come
on but I know not so good today
we've got to the the hotel now but you
have a sheet like to toe
what what you have to do what time with
pretty much is on whatever I've come a
late for the walk so I've had to wait
for them to come back and this is my
first time being with the squad so
imagine that
so obviously Keegan assert me that he's
eager for yeah he shot me sat me down
he said come stand up everyone see and a
few he put me on blast in five everyone
if you ever come late for work again
this your first time being a blah blah
blah I think at the time it was angry
because he knew we wanted to involve me
and all the players are seeing his part
it was my first time I need to get used
to these things I know in our so his
blood he's put me on blast and he said
I'll fine you for all your wages your
even did you have to take out them go
teeth I remember him going crazy laws
that are I'm sorry Godfather this is a
mistake or anyway now gone to the boss
now it's time to travel to Emirates and
then did anyone see anything after you
after that to you I need a large I think
one of the French let that come on bro
you have to be you know the desert or
bars that I definitely sorry so yes this
Emirates is a hybrid that time
Emrys my arm at that time and I remember
because they tell you like a coach goes
past obviously to gaffers at the front
Keegan's alone
and I think McDermott compost bench
bench bench bench because you got you
obviously got it starting eleven then
he's got the bench bench bench bench but
then he said you miss out that two of us
miss our youngsters miss out but I've
got the tap on a shot like bench on that
I mean I'm actually that time for him
what does that what does bench mean that
what does bench me you're under bench or
like you're involved in bars there I
texted everyone warm on the bench on
event walking through the Emirates at my
did this actually happen this is a dream
come true
anyway now no story short we lost that
game but I remember him saying you ready
like you ready like 76 minutes have gone
by you ready I'm there like it in my
head no but yeah you have to say yeah
you know I mean sighs I uh yeah I'm
ready you know I mean and then woman not
now I'm not
didn't get on that game but after that I
started getting a little tasters and
here and there sort of thing in a he got
sacked having heat another sacked after
Dan I don't know you coming after he
walked Keegan actually because you're a
[__] Barney was someone who's a [__]
relation someone replacing was it
Christie chris no no I see you I can't
it was after that joking it that's right
right making me [__] videos me yeah
cuz joking I was calling you on khabar
you on kebab yeah oops
ob yeah I mean it must be confusing for
an old guide you know me to come in and
just have to he didn't look healthy when
they gave him the job in there made you
have a relationship with key like did
you ever it will get to champion if he
can state he would have been on to me
out of just shotshell food he gave my
chance definitely right
and did you will you get in like to you
you felt you feel like your game is
evolving at that point like you were
learning training yeah yeah well do year
after yeah and it Scioscia Shera
coming ended your contract didn't it
shared it and sausage' not joking when
Joe Kinnear come I wasn't involved
really just said ah yeah you're that kid
was good in Academy yes or complimentary
neck I remember your name yeah you can't
remember skeletons no usually no Chuck
goodnight from going nearly Ranga
so in the championship I remember you
being used quite it was like you and
Andy Carroll yeah and you got you got a
few chances in the chocolate chips so
that season when sharing and are you
coming I remember like he come in they
said that everyone done all the players
will go out and that we're gonna have
something in the top top the clubs in
Newcastle I we're gonna have someone
watching so there's nothing actually
going on anymore
the old boys were going on
all that raving and we're doing bad I'm
good in terrible and everything like in
that season was people just taking the
piss piss he canapes I remember we had
to go to go out and nights out we'll
have to go travel to lead and have an
out
and what do you do that would be ideally
at one or two times I obviously you
gotta live your life and even though
we're losing you still gonna live your
life you know I mean why not take them
not take the pieces that you know I mean
going into top top one [__] on your
own doorstep mascara and you're just
gonna get a hell of a fine when you get
into chained in that Michael because my
question is that some people like that
balance you know what I mean like if
they if they only work then all work and
no play makes y ver jackie Doughboy ever
did you feel like you were a better
player when you could relax in between
and go out and do those sorts of things
or will you just follow in game top top
you know at that age I was hungry you
know I could go I have an out come in a
bit steam in a little bit and still be
on job because I was so hungry literally
I just wanted to get to the top yeah so
as one of them things really but it
doesn't the thing is I think it's more
of a sign of respect for me so like if
the team's winning and you see a few
footballers out enjoying themselves in
it no one gives a [__] no one but when
you're as bad as we were that's easy
no all bad in it's like a it shows a
lack of understanding about yeah the
funds feel like he's so [__] enjoying
themselves even a little whiff up and
paying a lot of money every passerby and
going what Ashley and Aoi
they put a ban on it was like oh she
really code because I know the Morton
and people like that like the clash was
she you they were not all went down can
you remember that when Barton was
clashing with Cheryl I was there but I
wasn't really involved like too tough
that I wouldn't really try and see
what's going on Oh ask I'll just hear
little bits
be a moment in a bit here and there I
remember um yeah but Cheryl was serious
money I missed about by he liked me a
lot he was that he's always hit me
that's a who's your agent
alright you're gonna talk to my agent
sort of thing like I like you Barbara so
he wanted to to you and give you a
contract for free no that's what I'm
saying lot of money
because of his faith in you as a key I
remember I was at the Academy said he
said I'm gonna give you a new deal and
you're now getting changed and the one
thing and I was oh my gosh things are
just getting better and well yeah yeah I
mean then that was a good deal as well
from what I hear a thousand bills I
think it was was a two five two grand
five hundred or even a fake and
geographic hundred were seventeen which
is a crazy amount of money I've just hey
so you're on like ten grand once at 17
years old I remember were the taxes and
as high as it was now right he was like
four faithful foods to face it wasn't as
bad you know I mean I mean I mean an
event that you would get a bonus being
on the bench if your team wins you get
bonus it was bonus I was crazy as well
so he eventually left I think Aston
Villa was his last game I've never been
in the squad and I wouldn't England
after but after that what was you know
the villa game we got relegated here
what was the mood like what was the lads
like I think the game is short it was
crazy that III would she cuz I was
outside and I knew that everyone getting
everyone getting so even players work
cuz I missed out that that that time I
was nameless good I was in the squad but
I pulled on a bit so he said to me yeah
like everyone come in well lads I told
you I've come I've had to put in a shift
but that literally everyone was
distraught that but I didn't work
whether they won't see the back of him
or what it was like what
it was just everyone was distraught and
luckily I didn't have to go on that on
that journey on the way back with them
because I didn't even want to know how I
been but I won't move England and then
I've come back the next season and the
championship share is left so I think it
they've left Chris who and pursue chart
and then yes Chrissie and anyway with
them well you can seems like a good
bloke yeah it was a good game and it was
used to always tell me that stop rushing
home to your girlfriend had a girlfriend
I said four years stop rushing home to
go for and mingle with the lads stop
just rushing off for hours I got first
you that cuz I was used to call him
Chris but then I started because of the
whole Keegan situation I said you know
cuz I'm he wasn't nowhere near like the
manager yeah so I think he Chris or
Christian
so I just couldn't Chris but then I said
you know let me be have man as a be
polite and say Gaffa because you're the
manager nice awesome yeah for what Jesus
and then start calling him kafir got
into the swing at that but he was giving
me chances that he was starting me in
championship games I'm a painting it's
less to get Amanda to match and I was
just thinking now it's happening I got
standing ovations right how's that
Newcastle people are noticing me in the
town I'm going to Tiger like every other
no oh my days is happening that because
I remember I said well Nando's as I can
t player nice to see people that going
out to all bar and all these players
that you know I mean but that the city's
like a fish boys that everyone knows
everyone and it sucker I don't know how
they fill out that stadium like that you
know I mean there's so much people in
new causes crazy that atmosphere that's
I swear to you I said I cut you card
that it's crazy that Macedo I've never
seen anything like especially how much
was your ego growing because like you're
going out now now yet like you're old
enough to go out on the piss girl's
[__] all over oh don't act like what
was that
that wolf of wallstreet moment like
where you realize art all [__]
enjoyable now I'm gonna [__] enjoy the
show when I think it was when I start
again because I was getting a quiet
money from bonuses then and I was like
what do I do that
say mom will you save it you're gonna
get a mortgage I was in a flat near
gates it they got some decent apartments
around but I was I was coming in late to
training all the time trying to get
through the better I was always late and
but they would find the hill I mean like
I saw it like it was just ridiculous the
fans I've got and eventually they got a
guy out of the gate with writing down
things like wow yeah we got serious and
you know Chris would do things that you
find a 300 pan then he'll get this what
was a problem you were told you have
what - yeah to do that was and it you
know
ya-ya-ya-ya-ya problem generally i think
here's the thing route get home from
training go to sleep wake up play my
game miss about mommy so ever and then
find it hard to get back to sleep right
like I told like three in the morning
four and one and then when it comes to
wake up in the morning struggle but
who's been leather throughout my whole
career that literally I don't know if I
got I don't know ways but I think God
obviously does work on not sleeping
shelter chain it have you ever thought
about that and been like I've got a
problem
yeah I should yes definitely but it's
hard to just see with me I can't say let
me organize musty okay 10:00 p.m. I'm
glad to see if I'm gonna cut roles my
other God can't do my Herodotus doors
after watching TV like whether it's two
and three and one
but snooze is a dangerous thing snoozing
that you see that but I'm there that's
dangerously it feels like you need
someone know to like literally be with
like hold your [__] hand is this just
to get work on time not it's mad but
actually shouldn't I should have to
depend on all unlike you know I mean
born alone die alone you shouldn't be
depending on someone to help you just
not that job you know I mean but it's
true they're watching this now door and
I'm feeling it like frustrated even
listening to you like why the [__]
called the sky just get up on time and
go to work like you're looking to do
what you do
like I'm sure you've had this that's had
a million [__] time I saw much yeah
it's like yes don't they don't get any
like what you're doing suffer you love
what's going on me like lychee I'm here
crafting my bollocks off your length of
five oh yeah these guys yeah you know I
mean so it's that come on but I
understand a little bit cuz you're what
you 1819 yeah so I do at that age we
will [__] up a bit right so I understand
that I think later on is where my talent
like my tolerance of that excuse just is
non-existent it's like at this age you
should know about obviously so this
there's an issue where your photograph
holding the gun as I do
got that one that was when I got to the
Premier League sort of thing that
eventually got too friendly so I
basically had a cause he's in a
championship down well you did got
promotion again do you know at that
point not that point I'm saying I was a
customer at that point I was like all
right Niles Ranger could be so maybe
Andy Carroll could be something like we
had some decent young players of night
or he was doing yeah Andy for you and
the for ofon D in terms of their eyes of
the funds it was I got a couple of good
young lancia this can [__] work out
but then Andy the next season would just
he had one of those seasons where you
have a touch of Gracie's yeah and he
smashed it yeah I think being Newcastle
he was always gonna be pushed a little
bit was he he hit the ground [__] on
it and I remember that what was he like
I see Andy he's a new and easy lunatic
he's a lunatic why he gets the job done
he dipped in scores then goes and he's a
presence when he's under me you know I
mean so he does his job he seems a bit
like you're in the party animal team
I think he's worse than me to be fair
he's a good bloke though I give it to me
got bad line he's a good guy touch on
him because I think Andy Carroll
talent-wise
has like is right up there like if he
could have stayed fit people would talk
about him in a totally different way
because he's sort of forgotten about I
mean hurricane came along he became
England's greatest Reich and I always
felt like if if Andy Carstairs fit for a
season you have a 20 goal of season
strike oh yes he will get you that go
and I had a giant his hands like that
yeah his head no I mean yeah dip in
who's that you know I mean what he can
he can play but I need he's a good guy
line in general I mean do you think he
had suffered a lot not as much as you
suffered but from similar issues of
looking after yourself
a new career yeah it's hard I think not
be Kevin he took him into his wing like
on his arm and said you know Alan it'll
cost you because you are tracker you're
scoring goals you're the man you know I
mean and and that helped him a lot Kevin
Nolan taking him under he's we know yeah
definitely because he's getting his car
blown up and stuff like that and you
possibly remember he's going for a lot
of [__] so you know I mean but then he's
still bummed on and carried on doing
well and he moved to Liverpool so good
on him yeah I think that's where say he
was like okay England now and then I
don't know what he's doing now he's just
probably just living life to be fed by
something tricky Club - yes that was
injured that was probably rumors but no
indeed he is heard he snuck out and
turds hurt his leg over it sounds like
him to be fair what sound different
sounds like him to get some juice so
what point do you decide I'm gonna take
a picture holding the gun and why and
why do you think that's a good idea at
the time I remember these times I've got
an avid yeah yeah so I played premier
league now I've had a few appearances
various also the copper teams and all my
gosh that I remember now 17 and on the
bench didn't diac wasn't even play and
now match he had the Emirates got kishan
he sent off and things are happening
that you know I mean Chris gave me that
chance and then was it I think it was a
game against Chelsea - - I think Stephen
Taylor scored after that they showed me
a paper of me that we need to talk to
you the students I come off the picture
i Stamford Bridge I was like what's
going on it all right what's going on
here like you know I mean and obviously
just before that I scored in it's like
things are going great got a new deal
new contract five and a half year then
they stack it's gone in the paper but it
was a BB gun I bought with my missus at
the time and I had the little target
thing in the garden I'll shoot in that
you know I mean I moved house I was
playing being a young boy a young man
you know I mean she's missing about
being reckless but
I took a picture and I pulled out my
what's up and then my mom said to me and
my family said take that out of your son
you crazy did so I took it off but I had
a bunch of people come every time they
can hurry oh my what's up to contact
Lisa at the time so couldn't be anyone
but I heard from a source that someone
made 9 grand of it but I was holding a
gun a BB gun
I got a missus to take at a time and
yeah I pulled my what's that saw
someone's grabbed off my water and sold
it to the paper I've come out of chat
Stamford Bridge and Lee Charlie has said
to me comment you see what's just double
spread papers like they printed the
paper before even come up they've got a
like a early tomorrow
this is coming out tomorrow I'm gonna
find you two weeks wages what do you
think I did the police at your house
right now as I speak saying when you're
your gun Pulliam are safe and at the
time I had a missus and I didn't want
her to know as am I say forever given my
cold but I had to give her the core than
me they got a burn where a guy on a pot
I think was going that was happening now
as a group
after that the Chelsea game so and I
think when zoom on in central London so
Campbell and the whole lot was a good
night but a great night the time yeah it
was all mayhem drinking are two weeks
wages I'm pissed off I remember they had
to put everyone's card into the thing
for food because they bill comment about
15 grand or 14 grand and I was that yeah
now you're a big boy now you could put
your card in is awesome and please like
please that I'm yeah I'm the young lad
IV pain don't occur you know I mean it
is that now we leave you out of it but
that was a big thing because pay Paul
you need to remember said you need to
now arrange a power opera or Mouse and
another thing or just which paper was it
the Sun paper makes sense the for the
record or one of the few lines I did
really like of my video is you think
your accounts are holding that good
not good in the other football I've
heard the same for nuking Newcastle was
so long I don't know why but someone
said your gangster first football a
second or something like that I keep
hearing that kills I've seen on Twitter
how's that he even said that what I
think someone said that after that I
don't know people fans I know goes he
spreads in it it feels I mean we all
know what happens to young black players
now on newspapers yeah does feel a
little bit harsh when you hear it's a BB
gun why did that did that come I think
therefore was there all gun yeah I
reckon it did it come out that it was a
BB gun I don't know you know it's like
it doesn't fit the narrative though
the next day would just just a
disclaimer here no Ranger you know not a
real gun it's not a real gun even you
didn't try and set the record straight
you were I said clearly you know it's
not a real gun go to the house and grab
the gun yeah if you want to do concede
and grab the pellets while you're there
the metal pellets really so you know
it's you know I mean but maybe you can
drill it to make her I don't know okay I
love that that was a no I think I just
want to just miss about in my god yes at
this point though with a few of the
things that's happened in the past dead
there's a name sort of starting to
develop at this point nothing like the
the bad-boy image is just beginning to
get good yeah then there's another room
I don't know how true this is that
someone got not though you're not
someone else and yeah dad gets or a few
I think that was there's been there's
been a few episodes on you I've hidden
it and so I think that's going down
further down like yeah I mean to into my
contract now obviously I don't think I
was playing at a time I've got my
cousins and I think I saw Merced Sutton
term what my ex like and said something
about maybe black some pickles on a hat
or and and he's calm and she had to
approach like he was in attacks off not
clima his friend out then I ran off then
I was hiding for ages I hide in for ages
but how's that I'm now arrange alike in
this town like people know who I am
there's no point I had been a camera for
ages I look back and I see this is
London or London was it new customs in
Newcastle and in
I've just said you know yeah let me have
my cellphone but I'll run for ages as
well blowing on my ass you know I mean
first the Train and he's done it three
test flights on time anyway I was
running how's that you know what
cool that I don't hand myself in give
myself up cuz they'll be a training
ground tomorrow it doesn't matter
yeah so I just did that I've got nicked
and then I've got a not guilty for that
to be fair but he was says yeah you were
put in the reserves for three months
again and then you were arrested again
for being drunk and disorderly yeah I
also saw the gaffer I think with part is
that hard you know it's hard to come
probably because Chris left off our
hearts got arrested on that night as
well yeah he's girl at Sur on a night
out he's like no this is way past the
London one now so we've got to UM he
said quite they say now Ranger will not
be in this team until his early or
something like that
right I remember that because you were
just was for a late night that I saw
commented no I did not I said you know
let me be on time so I can get back into
the squad
so I did that for like four weeks on
time and then he said okay you're gonna
be involved against Southampton I
started gradually getting back into the
squad I saw yeah you are trainable you
are teachable do you can't learn a
[__] lesson you're not a complete
lost cause here I have Fela alright and
managers like you they do but then it's
like I take the piss right lat I would
turn up there sometimes always even sick
like I've come from there yeah I'm I'm
Laura yeah yeah your ring early and from
the physio on the Dawkins arm
but there's to say coming that you still
after coming about you eventually coming
back when your own time but I'm smelling
alcohol like yeah they know yeah I'm
just yeah so this is when did the drunk
and Disorderlies think up was this one
so this is after you how is it in the
knows drink driving all right okay I
think that Jesus audio junk there's so
much I did to drunkenness hood there was
one way at one time was
and pesto I sweat she does one timers
are done with junk of the studio to
Halloween was supposed to be out cuz we
had to travel a few days later I
shouldn't be doing that obviously a few
days before each other and on matchday
but when I said [__] it Halloween when I
was wearing it I was literally wearing a
mob would online a convict white and
blue lines and they're like a color
would well that's a tumor yeah exactly
so go out there this guy's be become
there and then basically been saying I
think I had an argument with someone I
had a big argument as long as my ex or
I'd argument and then women are a
problem here yeah that we already
covered that
yeah you're gonna get to that yeah but
yeah so I was arguing arguing I said
this is disagreement so stay out of it
the offices stay out stay out of it I
wasn't even drunk was a drinking that
night anyway now the offices scene who I
am me are you still funny
I'm still giving it you still gave it
you that's it you're on the rest of that
right you know just take me to the
station just make it quick so people
don't see me then they've long they are
we have to wait for the feeling there's
to it for the Carter [__] as how you
don't arrest him I'm not even drunk like
where's drunken disorderly that it don't
make sense
got to the I got to the station I'm not
okay if I've been nicked for drunk and
disorderly breathalyze me or do
something why am I going to cool cuz
I've come at a sauna so you're going to
cool tomorrow I thought your skip man
you're in the convent let me keep that
on they took it off straighten they'd
let me keep down they took it off so
how's that you know are crazy you went
from one convict outfit to another
convict and bland t-shirts they're like
listen this is a joke I'm gonna jump oh
you know playing a breathalyzer we do
whatever furthermore I know a lot of
people would do this week in week out
drunk and disorderly yeah a 90-pound
fine why am I going to cool cuz I hurry
up and then he sent me to cool do you
feel like it's not anything but of
course am that was another thing I mean
I was traveling to the airport because
we still got on a private plane so we're
forward
come figures against all this was the
playing at Stoke house just getting back
into the team I've done my four weeks
a little probation where I got in on
time wherever and then yeah there was
that to me Oh John Carper for me John
Carver mm-hmm he phoned me that I'm the
greatest crazy is that great he's that
no just wanted to know the greatest
coach in Premier League history no
listen
the calf is just told me you just turn
around turn around and go on
no I'm not why do I said me I don't know
I don't know but you got to turn around
now you know involved so who that
probation the forward sortation and then
get into the air points that you turn
around actually getting to the airport I
have to turn around just when I'm
getting back into the team is ridiculous
and what why did you have to turn around
you because of that yeah they come out
in the press or someone contacted the
club before we keep that lower body it's
good the next thing we've got here in
the list is apparently you smashed your
girlfriend's front door in a minute so
my my exhales try it was trouble with my
ex she must have said she live with me
at the terminus she said yeah I'm gonna
go back to London I was like no you're
not you ain't gonna know it so she went
to training I went to training then she
said to me ah I've gone back to the
house and she's not there I'm thinking
well so I said to I remember saying to
the gaffer are literally something spoke
with family bla bla bla just to go and
chase her lightly Chooch so I chased her
when they went to issues live in and I
basically said are you gonna open a door
bar no I'm not there to Newcastle what
the wrong then end up kicking off the
door getting nicked and that was another
thing like yeah so they did the kafirs
are foods going there for family issues
and you're kicking of your girlfriend's
daughter getting arrested so that was
another thing and now really old
apparently you saw him kidnapped
possibly I mean that's a reason all
right so can I just pick up on my
comment over just a second because that
also then sounds like you're still
slightly taking the piss a little bit
that definite like what exactly just
lying I'm not through Matti fly I'm dead
like listen I've got family she says
yeah go for it do you ever do you end up
getting the rest of the same night so
it's just like one thing after another
it's like this is it nice and taking a
piss and these times I'm just about
getting back into the team that it was
yeah it's like an elastic band affect
your career is just when you almost
we've got the science trip just like
that litchi yeah and and from what I'm
reading this is where it starts getting
really [__] bad because at that point
like my video was out that really didn't
help your friend out down that sounds
much sorry but like you know I had a
point every fear but you know there's
there's the bad boy name and then you
get arrested on suspicion of rape all
right do you want to tell us like
because yeah I feel like the rest is
quite choppy and we can laugh about it
nice this is like your life is over
taste [__] yeah well Cristiano Ronaldo
is currently being accused of this song
say every obviously now I think in the
Lord I think it's happening in our girls
gorgeo and they're telling hips you know
I mean because even that Gawker now what
a friend was still is the Newcastle
she's gone out to him recently and said
ah yeah now I've didn't really do
nothing to me he was just I loved it
black but I was just I had a boyfriend
at the time I feel bad so I was like wow
so how did you know this girl and what I
wonder how amazingly and we just want to
say before you say that sorry
yeah there's two sides to every story so
like you know I'm not saying that
everything you say is I get into it that
I'll get into it yeah a little bit here
and it so these times that Newcastle
that I'm trying to get back into the
team where Vardhan that was that the
last drawer literally even with the
drink driving you to drink diving
who didn't so if we've heard now I was
had my mrs. whatever and led to be Latin
I'm guest so you can say Gaston known
I'm going clapping all the time I'm not
in the squad song Viki [__] you I don't
I know I'm going out tonight
Chyna Jack people leave me that and
they're like no I meant training to more
of us all gonna I know the night hours
here a girl she looked all right and got
a number of what I said this to me
showed me up sometime bah-bah-bah so
we've met now and then we've gone to
auto I've had a bit of foreplay one
night and then have you drinkin at this
point yeah another time
going what can record another time we've
gone now I'm had a drink combat off a
little bit why she was that no I've got
my boyfriend bar so I was that cool no
problem you know I mean and then sorry
just be absolutely clear that's a really
weird thing for anyone to say if they
arranged to go to a hotel room this one
kiss someone and then go in like no
boyfriend no so let's be asleep yeah
cool and I was respectful as that what
we're doing for having for please yeah
mmm corn or mixed signals quote mixed
signals cool I'll get this cold core cap
if you don't do nothing we just so you
didn't try in persuader no ma'am
oh yeah you don't need to know anything
you don't need more sludge would say in
that scenario they would try and talk
her into it if that's what they wanted
yeah there wasn't black yeah let's do
that
it was that okay no foreign boy you
don't need to know that yeah ba steel
cool went back you gave up eventually
gave up that's cool no problem another
time whenever you're ready that was
we'll meet up and we can try again bay
city any now still not in the squad or
nothing
my ex missus is pissed off of me at the
time so she's friends also go in
Newcastle's it's going to work from
there so now I said you know I've got a
day off tomorrow
[__] yeah I'm gonna go up I said to her
texture that were you up to you are you
doing you wanna go out and have some
drinks
we've gone had some drinks her drunk
these times she's dancing
all over me lap dancing basically on me
on the CCTV and everything but yeah I
was I was I was that cool let's go to
next cup we're going to top table where
she used to work and then she I think
from there
she said blowbacks you know they had the
little pen she shall oh yeah if he's
doing that she shall blowbacks basically
kissing and then she must have said from
there she was too drunk to remember
anything right but she's still working
top top so I think on the CCTV shows her
hugging bouncer what is the work there
but my sister's they said if you forgot
everything how do you remember to hug
this bouncer yeah another thing I see an
Instagram post today where it says if
you're out with a girl and she holds the
bouncer abort mission abort me right
she's seen that this morning right
dammit you should have got no I swear to
you anyway now I've got into the taxi
so your drum head rebuff oh I had to
kiss you know everyone eventually got to
the hotel and then she sat down for a
bit because I feet were her and she went
it was over then we've gone up to the
room but I've opened the door like in
the LOB like in the corridor no open the
door then she's got our back and walking
behind me like like nothing's happening
she's cool going to do you know what
went down and then the next stage so she
was fully into it fully into you and the
next day she's texting me I wake up next
to each other now she was gone in the
morning
yeah woke up well stanzol wake up on us
you're there but then she's she's gone
the next day and she's texted me that
are as they are make sure you come and
watch it saw said something just
remember technical texting like normal
anyway was that dance music Robbie shoes
to text that noon anyway I go home now
got a banging headache two days later I
get knock at the dorm that why you not
bothering me again what you don't want
and those that are we arresting you for
section one rape something like that I
was like wow that
and had a friend teammate at the time I
said listen sharp my agent blah blah
blah the arresting me but these times I
got into the I got into the cell they
searched me but I had another phone when
I was missing I don't trust police so I
had to another phone so I was texting
like listen I need to scream on me and
this girl's chest because I think the
police might do you suffering Toji so I
trying to do that by my phone dead and
my sister said they've looked for this
hour for more you tool or talking on
they can't find it they've got her phone
they need your phone so I said I could
take it there's a key now you can they
can investigate a way over and then you
can go get bail but how's that to my
sister
do you think this is gonna come out and
the press and I don't need that for
myself I'm not gonna get no touching
because that same day hall and the
championship
I feel no further Suffolk I got a phone
call saying from Steve Bruce in yeah we
want we want you to come in for whole
want you to pou be a good asset for us
borrow brah so I was got us in too much
I do - I try stick out Newcastle I was
talking to my cousin on her phone at
what should I do
she'd go to home and smash it and then
you never know what can happen his
championship
so that's come out now I'll be you see I
Septimus astaizzu , he said to me nice
not actually you know that yeah so it's
every lice all over the place and it's
on BBC canary for city imagine a new
come on no one knows yeah like can you
describe cameras are sad when I got
there I was pissed allows that hour so
pissed off you know your Pierce like
things are not paying were already you
trying to get into the team that okay
you want to go to hole everything was
shut down after that no team sucks oh
yeah for I don't think that people
understand or especially I mean you were
found not guilty and she will get that
book the my life is over kind of feeling
that you must have gone because really
rape is not yes you don't just put that
you know Stephen and there's other
things that you've done in the past
where you know it's wrong but there's
that it's just a different level of
wrong so like and your name is is never
gonna be the same again I was getting no
chance that he beats up his wife he
beats up is what we would everything
that she said no no she said no all
these chants I'm thinking wow this is
what's going on that and that's not
gonna stop even when I get her club in
the future is still gonna continue
because unknown as this controversial
player you know I mean yeah but things
are nice they need to take serious and
girls should really get done for that
like because using cool the whole time
lying
my sister says she's gonna cry a few
times and pretend she's what kind of
things did she accuse you of from memory
she does I don't really just said
basically yeah I didn't get consent
basically she said but my sister just
cross-examiner that so why did you go
back to the hotel what do you think is
going to be played twists are like what
do you think was gonna go down that
literally what pay board what do you
think she started crying would've that
anyway
yeah I'm still sure yeah the judge said
right this is a five days nail and in
them five days I got arrested like twice
like in them five days they said
basically my hotel was in the town I
can't jump from London these tunnels
were Swindon as well I know I left the
aisle if and as we Swindon was my case
is gonna because it's that you are alone
right now
sorry I said mutual consent they ended
the contract at this point I mean soon
then and then I still had the case on
dying literally there that the officers
would show me must is a little bit of
footage of that scene line of like her
walking looking a bit drunk like they
wouldn't show other bits my sister said
buying a shiner and it was like now we
don't have to he was like listen like
the prosecution was saying they don't
know this is yeah this was know this was
in this interview or that you don't
saying don't say nothing now that's my
fave that's what and I'm in structure do
you say nothing because they're not
showing us nothing that I've got all day
muscle so say for you to show me that
and then I don't want to show you that
because
it they they had no case that you know I
mean and that would have helped us that
because she was all over me dancing they
did want a short they showed that their
shoulder shoulder in the trial look they
show Diana child and she was just crying
and doing all that so the judge said
this is not one a unanimous decision
I don't want free saying guilty for said
you know I mean I want unanimous you
don't have to agree together if he's
guilty he's good if not he's not if you
need further indication where I think
these things going then no means I hope
what did you feel like on the day well
you've got not good is I just jump for
jail at Wow cuz a bar paid so much fees
out like it was still like a loss of elf
to me but it was like I can continue and
focus on my career and get things done
like you know I mean that did you feel
like that still stuck with you a little
bit of course of course
that's never good no matter what where I
could go to Rome which is tomorrow
that's still gonna be from you know I
mean and you just can't trust females
it's hard to and players coming up now
making money they're gonna have birds
friend their pants at them friend
themself at them everything it's now
about you even just when they [__] a
girl they're having to pay them just to
not see anything is for nothing just
just saying I [__] you now you don't
say anything to the press about this I'm
gonna pay you just to shut up that's
like that's mendel to me like you can't
for all like men get a lot of [__] in
the mainstream media for men to have to
be that [__] careful about that's
[__] the girls in someone it's just
matter yes to do when you're actually
somebody lies it's crazy and what girls
got like the tricks they got on their
sleeve it's ridiculous why just get a
nine-to-five and just work hard like you
know I mean why you have to rely on
someone else
Chaitanya someone nothing I feel sorry
for people who are real rape victims
person well because like I remember one
time way a couple of my mates went to is
up on a girl basically she was fully
consent and she was an onslaught and she
[__] loved it and then the next day
my mates being popular loud she was like
oh this is gonna get out so I need to
find a way to spin this as if yeah
that girl and she accused our charge I
know my miss do you know you know you're
missed
exactly what up someone's [__] you
know it's scary when when I got
chocolate when they charged me do they
make kept make him a compensation there
we can charge up our charge it
then when they eventually charged me it
made people think that we're all so you
got charged in what really went down
then yeah I must have something they
must have shown your cross wonder I know
when a Caesar look in someone's eye
thinking what you don't but what you
really think I did that offering that
even then you're thinking wow like
that's it can make someone think there's
a school of thought which is wrong which
is that and I've kind of thought this
myself sometimes is someone with that
level of Fame would never do something
like that and then you've got people
like Bill Cosby and you've got people
who are famous who still [__] very
famous at yeah I respect the whole me to
thing is based completely off famous
people who shot people a lot pub in
there done terrible thing that I guess
that's kind of the problem that we have
here is like because it's such a
personal thing it tends to be between
one maybe two three people sometimes you
are in your bed it's basically your word
against theirs
and if you're not have any CCTV footage
or anything like that then you're very
unlucky at that point it's also that you
could this is the important that is
yours you may be sitting in a cell and
if you don't have a solicitor or
whatever and the police are trying to
force a confession out of you of course
anything out of you you begin to doubt
yourself even if you are of a strong
mind you'll still begin to doubt
yourself course there are points where
you began to think should I have got
consent should I have what
were there times he bent began to
question yourself no because I just knew
the whole time was consensual like right
up she did that to put everything pants
off like she was just on you know I mean
that so kissing you know you know the
usual in the bedroom to antics done what
we had to do and then maybe she felt bad
after about boy for maybe who knows what
to bring dragged me through that mess
wherever they went through it's crazy
because after that had to start
literally when I was meeting girls and
getting jiggy wit girls I would have to
record have a recording on my phone
please and record it yes they are
me so have you got facebook miss that
that's you black yeah Oh
what's your facebook what's your name
like fully like your full name so I can
add you on facebook she was their full
name and look at me like I'm a weirdo
but little does she know I'm Chyna
record because I don't want that [__]
happening again
and I'll say that I missed you did you
have fun last night was it fun yeah we
have fun yeah of course why you ought to
give me that nice stop record at the
name so if they did comma die again I'll
horseshit position that mate just let me
out now but right about that what who
dug it was it yeah that's her name is
[Music]
scary in it like it's sad you don't have
to live like that but there's so I open
up for all these young footballers
coming up making their money and dating
women and doing that I guess it's worth
saying both ways as well it's like there
are there will be a lot of people who
will have seen what happened with Bill
Cosby and happen what all these big
celebrity guys we don't know what's
gonna happen with Ronaldo so it's best
to leave that out but I think there's no
about that to be yes he's been a great
man and that's crazy
we don't we don't know what how that's
gonna come out we don't know what's
going to come out in the case and in the
washer over but there will also be
people who see girls who are have
actually been raped called [__] called
all these sorts of things this is a fear
and that will put girls going through
actual rape yeah do you know I mean yeah
so this is ridiculous for these hungry
yeah girls it's China get quick money I
could change our sign that there's
actually people getting raped at this
yeah Nicola so I think that's not funny
she mess about that that's why in the I
think the new law is that girls are
getting sentences which is a great thing
because I won't be the first I won't be
the last for this things that is gonna
happen to like people are gonna get do
you know I mean point they need to make
sure they do the right things that out
the right outcome is done because it's
ridiculous or in someone's life
okay when someone's actually can ruin
someone's life litchi I remember as that
every data I'm on bail for rape that yes
this is a joke that this is crazy
like what's going on he doesn't make no
sense and everyone's when you get
charged as everyone's Decatur you be in
charge now me yeah so be not so it
really [__] pisses me off this
because there's there's so many people
like you know that once again real rape
victims who [__] me through horrible
[__] who then are the reason that so
people don't trust them it's because of
these [__] who get found out
pointing the finger up guys like you who
just drunk whatever it's like ridiculous
just [__] disgusting scary scary scary
that's why you know missus no I'm just
I'm just chilled I don't deal with that
you know I mean that's the best thing
just focus on getting back to the top it
shows that relationship power dynamic
very light sex is a powerful you know I
mean cool yeah but there's some dodgy
girls out there tell you that for free
yeah so when you then come out the other
side of that court case you're you're
squinting like at Swindon but then I got
into another location and just read not
honestly which attent you here I can't
believe you got into this sort of stuff
because you seem like such a it was like
right people say when the media kill me
but it's that when you see me in person
and get to know me it's a different
thing yeah you see him you seem like you
seem like a nice guy you seem stupid you
made so many stupid decisions on what
but like what what was the next one in
criminal damage I think oh you brought a
taxi drivers window yeah I remember that
I was in after the taxi driver called
you a rapist yeah I remember that and I
was like finger to a night out few more
meets and then guys you know when that
taxi ranks and the first call you get in
so I've tried to get into not junk off
my head and I remember the guy but I
remember everything on him but a guy or
me I don't want you my high yo-yo raped
it's like I was that what I was on my
head that was gonna be getting on and
she smashed the back of his taxis and
getting off then I got back to the hotel
because they you've obviously found the
police whoever said now range of our I
was booked into auto my name everything
mommies or nothing and
Nietzsche pulled up to my hotel got into
my room and then I got a knock on the
door
officers nicht and then yeah I was it
pay some damages Richie and there was
another I think after was another
criminal damage I think he's out there
I'm looking
yes Swindon John T all right it's five
goals in your first eleven starts stop
as a regular and then stop training
stop turning for training that's gone so
one for you though five goals in 11
starts when I went missing and I heard
so much things that we weren't you know
you and we know you went missing where
did you go I was in my flat I was in the
flowers in my flat just chillin just
softly come off me I just didn't wanna
go in and I don't know where it was a
sweet little you know I was in the
aftermath of the rape kit had you go now
still in are still in it
do you reckon you could have been like
and I'm a [__] going through like I
don't know if I was anyone but I don't
know it was an ongoing rape case it says
he says yeah yeah you do you just think
that you were like given it being
stressed academics just started because
it's not easy taking that type of charge
and hearing that [__] when you're trying
to do good for yourself let you know
once that you know I mean that so I
could've been going for a stage are that
our faysville as I'm never going to copy
odds so I can actually understand that
if that was the reason behind I'm not
sure I'm not sure so I'm not gonna read
you right I'm not sure what I remember
so far back I remember why I wouldn't
miss it for ages like she didn't I said
you know I thought about the change to
do it because I need to I know things I
watch him I know I can do this and I'm
doing well for my sauce so I remember
this period I wanted you to and [__]
around because I was like it would be
good if I could do a video later on down
the line of fair play at the pool
because I'm not like a hater
yeah I'm really not but um I think there
was footage kmo which I've just read
that I remember where you're having some
issues at the door and you're in [__]
with a girl and then you slice girl free
I'm
I remember being like all my days and I
was like this is it that's it
that was that was it yeah what what the
[__] was going on there cuz I think
along your journey I'm like yeah and
came to understand that and his things
yes yeah that I totally I hand like that
was my friend what's still my friend now
like you know I mean there's CCTV just
so people know of you slapping a girl
outside of her house or whatever and
it's like yeah now you've you [__]
Weleda in the finish i was really i
water
you know is idea i black tar and i drank
like i think it was a bottle and a half
a Hennessy that way it's my birthday and
I'm obviously this girl's my friend but
she said to me the next day like
obviously the door he's shot
so I've kicked the door I don't remember
what it is that kicking the door kicking
a door and then I think she told me that
my keys and my pocket the next day she
said I was telling you like your keys in
your pocket and I was still kicking his
door and then she was arguing with me
and then obviously I put my hand in
there she said I put my hand and I was
that I don't remember none of this stuff
you know I mean out there like you're
lying because she's like now trust me
that I know we play about we always mess
about but you went too far this time
like you actually become I and she had a
little [__] us what the [__] of them
and how's that I'm so sorry I don't
remember none of that like she's died I
knew I know you don't remember that but
obviously like he did it then I was like
I'm so sorry like Ritchie because I
don't I don't condone him that that's
not that's not the guy I'm yeah that's
that was crazy and so and I saw that I
was like wow I directed I need to stop
drinking from there I just cut down
drinking and nichy because I had to
drink a lot and I don't remember nothing
from it a black car like that don't know
suffer my dream whatever it was I don't
remember it so just it was ridiculous
well no I mean yeah no it's not when
Swindon got really nice in and said you
know what mutual consent pay you out and
then you have to just good luck to
yourself like you have to find the next
Club and after Swindon I remember but
yet that one that one's still after now
that's still on when I learn so I pass
it they told me that someone had to
the door so the person was fixed the
door seen as me and got a little money
of it again I'll yeah yeah it's a cool
thing about that thousand me and the
other members was ridiculous do you
reflect I mean you didn't think you were
capable of that see that that obviously
I just got not guilty on on that girl
and then that to me come out and then it
was that what the [__] that yeah you
know I mean this is crazy that this
looks like I'm some crazy woman be I
like you look ridiculous
yes or how's that my date I think I
thought like I've never felt so low
after everyone don't think to you put a
big star that miss my big star clubs
touching me I've never fallen in a
manager I mean what manager was can is
that I think you might have been Ian
Holloway I'm not sure and who's that
I've got to us I saw on the video that
you create I'll never say I'll never
touch you even watch Paul a yeah well
this is crazy that took an effect on me
for a long time even not to know yeah
when when he's saying that what are you
what you thinking when I seen it when
he's speaking to you nothing and so like
I've seen people do [__] and be like
irate and been like felt it yeah and
he's clearly watched that and felt like
he did she you screaming that me like I
was his son no I know hey [__] you know
crazy you don't really have people
scream at you like that in the past so
what was that like mmm I have but hardly
by it was that Wow disguise she because
he's teased to always like me and say I
want to sign your on to bring you here
that's disappointment that so he's good
he's good are you yeah it was it went
down as far as you did and inside what
you doing that you you think you are
what was going from you what you
thinking at the time
oh you're on drugs already found at that
time I doubt it because I thought cool
the next day but you never know I was
junk I drank a bottle and a half a
Tennessee lead she's done myself
I was finished blacked out
nothing cuz that was where I was I know
this is this is it really like this
there's no coming back from that
yeah as I thought and in I don't know
what happy after Finland Blackpool here
really yes
you signed 150 pound a week with a 33
pound a minute playing board or are ya 3
grand bonus you did alright for them
though didn't you
it's alright aunty too bad but obviously
I was basically telling the chair minute
oh I was telling the chairman and I'm
Angela I can't really I don't like how
you've put me on this wage um no I have
to do this I'm trying to get myself back
on a map but this wage is ridiculous I'd
like before my fridge it to you if I
have to jump out of challenges
I don't wanna jump out a challenge
that's not a player I am I want to be
involved for me but if I get injured
I'll be in life if they said ridiculous
partly to get bonuses apparently you
went AWOL again for family reasons but
one of the things that have been said is
there's certain situations going on
nobody knows the full picture
can you remember I said that yeah this
is a court from just around that whole
time nor like you what I did so you just
gave up basically it was a thing where I
just said you know I think what's that
managers judy's to play four leagues off
the clock from Latin me a lot but even
he was thinking like this contracts
ridiculous like he's one of our best
players is a bit ridiculous but he don't
think you had no say today change the
chairman ready knew he had me the
Chairman's that car I stand the Chairman
that used to tell me listen you're one
of our best players I don't know why
muscles put you on that contract
maybe senior situation I thought let me
use it to my advantage you know I mean
but yeah they did seem quite unscrew
damodar's Tosh so I said you know can
take this normal I'm going left and
obviously you know I had an issue mark
cause I got shot in his foot and there's
a few family issues but that was a big
issue for me as well like the money the
wage you can't me even are you still
getting are used
pretty comfortable off of the Newcastle
deal at that point because that was a
decent wasn't like 20 grand a week
contract or something I die everyone
thinks that cuz you don't match it at
the end [__] long and now I was that or
than think it was nine night I was 2019
I was on nine my bonuses were good the
bonuses are pushing on it it's a trailer
you have like money going into a bank
account that you couldn't turn you were
a certain age so what age was do you
allow to touch the five alright so how
old you 27
yeah Amy says well you've had access to
that money for the last two years Nike
car another extension on it
so yeah cuz until an IV Messiah yeah we
my mind work she don't miss about she
thinks every bit it's my last night you
know I mean you guys so you've still got
that money and honesty still they're
biased like can't be touched until I'm
free basically done did I mean finish my
career so it's just it's a bit of
headache so then I've been it's been
hard to get by and it's been there's
been money there little bit by it's been
hard as a kind of function but she's not
trust me and not even one bit maybe
rightly because of because that new
cause who I had a serious gambling
problem I see add some I was I mean my
goal on [__] school on the jury
bottoms commenting but I just had a
serious problem like I was DG grinder
every day every single day and then it
got to stage of the chairman at
Newcastle might actually Daryl and
biases like we're banning you from every
cos you know what what we do we go into
tables i watch the tables can see just
going doing too much and listen listen
we own casinos and things we know how
it's gonna go like literally you need to
stop doing this not yeah so you know
it's bad many people who are in the
casinos Regina don't yes and I didn't
listen I was too young my speaking on
where I've got five year deal here I'm
how am i around that bills China help me
what angles have to be on it still
trying to help me but just wasn't
listening going through one ear out over
mmm
you got signed by South End and I had a
spell out for ages though yeah on a
one-year contract and then it says you
got charged for an incident that took
place in February 2015 where
frauding a woman out of 2,000 pounds
you've got eight months in prison but
you served eight weeks what was your
involvement in that fraud because this
is Hollis it wasn't much I just put a
friend to someone who knows about that
life and from there that friend got into
a pickle because the Suffolk deputies in
the car his account what did they charge
you with then how did they manage if
you're just the hookup
how did they manage he said my name to
them he put me through to him and blah
blah blah so they said that I was the
influence on it and I should have known
better something like that implicate yes
Dave yeah so I was like whoa like how
you gonna do that to me that seems a bit
wishy-washy to be honest with you like
that seems like you're not because for
them to pin this on you I mustered they
must had some evidence don't know about
the evidence that the island hexane yeah
I'm gonna put you through to this guy
our part text messages and it will
you'll my friend he still you were you
were aware of the game that they were
running on people yeah I said here go on
just this is a guy I know Barbara and
from there just went pear-shaped because
three Texas because the judge said
Ranger this could be a big thing this
could be a kid like that's what happens
when your name you got a name a little
name I just wanna know if you hadn't
learned your lesson by that point like I
I was trying to help someone out like
lychee I know a bit crafty bars out here
god this guy I know he's a bit dodgy
that girlfriend right and then end off
missing me up so I think so it is mattre
it was crazy so but it was old Indian I
said you know this is a joke you know I
mean I'm trying to get fear and get a
new club I already had so much else and
taking so much knocks that I need to get
so you know did you know what these dogs
were doing the people like fraud an
amount of money and stuff and well
obviously I knew some it was how much
did you know enough to know the
ergonomic money off the lawn yeah no I
never suggested my friend said he wanted
to make a bit of money so just a few
taxes that shows that I kind of showed
him the way basically right so [__] me
man
first game after your tag was removed
you score and you celebrate taking your
boot off and shooting it as if it's a
machine gun
I remember by the way listening to the
radio on that day and hearing the
commentators say now Ranger the first
came back I was just taking his boot off
and everyone just going no I know I
plied loved it I took it to my friends
Jame McGlashan a few Robinson on that
day and I was that to them I listened
you know you know that guy am
my Kadapa you know my godfather tingly
right yeah speaking he was talking about
on the channel that you know I think I
stole out of him my friend Fury's is
that I'm gonna do that celebration
together and not before me I'm gonna
score first so and that's going a penny
and I said you know what let me do it
and I tried to do within the beat but
then obviously I was off a little bit
but good enough is good enough
I checked the officer I'm gonna be a my
blitz are doing it might be off quickly
all right and then yeah from there this
is a chance for mutinous this is a real
[__] chance for you to recover again
self and you could score goals this is
your back to the top and then the the
get rid of you because of Rhea Rhea
current disciplinary issues as you know
I am keeping she well why why you goes
that obviously that I did well when I
signed for them they Fort mean like I
think of grand or something and then I
got a new deal and then that fool thing
come out obviously had that season with
them but then I went Joe during the
someone and then I come out and I was
groggy
man I was gorgeous anything I've missed
so much three seasons I was groggy I
thought rubbish that our borrows China
graft and get back to everyone's fitness
that so it was hard when you miss a
preseason is hard and then you say you
were trying nor like if someone who
trained review at that point was
listening this would be their but they'd
be like yep all Shan
are you ready are you [__] tree normally
I have I can't be lazy but this time you
know I'm not consistent like one day I
might be on fire next day I'm like I
used this guy she you is described no oh
yeah cricket player like who is he you
know I mean so it was a bit mad but when
I'm on it I'm on it that's why I play as
I range get on it like really common
range like they always give it to me
song and amp myself up and and go hard
really but I can go missing and chain
and definitely easy so which is bad
because actually the place you need to
prove yourself is training right I use
in turn and when I come out of Joe
obviously it was just late so on it
wasn't knocking someone out or doing
something that outrageous relates that
players a listen range they're taking a
piss man stop now why can't you just get
up on time then I think some players
told the manager that even rigged a
phony through for a brand at the time he
was like you taking a piss like I can
only back you for so for so long that
you're not a Lincoln it was not like to
me when I hear these things I'm like
Ronaldo's on time ESI's on time why the
[__] should people make an excuse for
you like I can't work yeah that's I
think it's the problem of me going to
bed straight after dreaming
litchi I'll tell the players knew that I
did they would love me don't like me I'd
be like you're a good lad but you just
you can't be late like it ruins the
whole squad and then you start that
you'll be late a couple days in the
weekend and you start a match what how
does that look for the other players
it's not looking good
it shows the other players that this guy
can do anyone like even if you trained
up and phoned it turned up and for and
in at least you're there on time and
you're showing respect for everyone else
disrespects disrespect and once is a bad
egg in a team did it's like it just
ruins the whole atmosphere and
everyone's or a lot so it's like it's
messed up so the team but the gaff was
getting on to me the Chairman was
getting on to me but they back to me
they bent over backwards to me both for
them and the team look great is all on
the staff so so when you wrong me you
were like I'm having like financial
troubles and all are we now at the stage
where a lot of people said you would end
up which is you know the money's run out
no one else
and what the [__] do you do now
uh almost there even could say almost
there
yeah that's the rule but I slack its
we're not there yet
in it we're not there we can still work
on [__] young but like young but
there's no chances going on there's no
chances and and financially it's not
easy I'm not on Newcastle waging a war
I'm not on nor wage anymore but I'm not
gonna do something dumb what do dumb
things to get that I'm gonna have to
just work hard because footballs my
talent song when they work hard but when
I support you on the phone it was like
you know I'm getting opportunity to
Train yeah but I'm not a trainer and I'm
like yes when I hear that yeah I'm like
what's not changed what you haven't
haven't change I mean it's difference
because I've been stung by a team by
doing the child fing Blackpool and then
getting a terrible contract with archive
and tackle nobody and then it's like if
I get injured I'm [__]
I don't want I know my bill yeah but
even my Billy people manager say yeah
it's good player but port in Suffolk in
my contract way it's like if this guy
messes around he's off her simple as but
pay me what what I deserve my what I'm
worth you know I mean but obviously it's
not that easy
team gotta trust you and build trust
I've been like I sell Vince that from
like four cups three cups
that's ridiculous you're in the in the
Football League you're you've got the
worst name of any player there was
literally one or two who literally don't
work that is she like neuringer no way
no chance that good player by never
don't even go near but they're still
Cubs out there now what are sniffing
about so what do you want to do about
that the Lakers they're not things you
could do I'll eat you have a snot I
could if I said I wanted to do an hour
in Jack Adam you can my cousin's doing
this I work right yeah but I'm thinking
what kids are gonna turn up until I have
to who are my image first think have get
like to have two seasons clean no lates
no nothing like that
they're not gonna start gradually doing
it definitely your book cuz my last like
a movie that's one thing I look up
literally that'll be good you want to
try to cure and die over
Dinah's oh yeah he's done money someone
yeah [__] unbelievable booth great
every day I read there's a few I read
queue and dyers book because it's fair
it's like how the similar story you but
obviously curing it achieved like you
did achieve a lot yeah but yeah there's
that the pitfalls in there you know I
mean and [__] the book
I don't know I I'd like for you to have
a happy ending and improve to people but
it's just it's hard man it's not easy
and every time I get a chance and do you
are start doing well that suffragists
grabs me but it's your stupidity mate
and I don't mean I couldn't you wait but
I think it is yeah I think you've got a
[__] good life ahead of you
you could still flip and turn around but
now and this is it right I'm being
honest because I've worked [__] hard
to get where I am and I swear to God
like you know I was just I was on a
council estate when I mean no I mean
[__] London now we're doing for them
well but when that opportunity comes now
like if you don't grab it now that's
like me you know the next seven years I
genuinely mean this you're gonna get
that money eventually that you'd had
saved up yeah but like you're gonna be
it's gonna it's all gonna go like you've
got yes it's still [__] yes bank
balance and create a career and be a
poster boy of like a [__] up are
turned around you could still do that
though still do it but it's hard it's
easier said than done but you have to do
Bessy imagine the last cover had
lates like you should be doing from
South from when I was at Southampton are
supposed to learn that do you know I
mean so and I mean it's because I want
you to [__] do well like look a guy
who's nearly 30 not getting on time for
a job what about your missus like you've
got one responsibility here something at
a time sure know you want to fight for
her you want to give her a good life all
of that yeah I need to switch on last
this - laters no you've got any kids no
that's a statically because they seem to
be looking after me maybe if that
happens all that my foot and kick your
leg as I swing that guy
what keep Marku pots and what keep eyes
that soon as you said range that have a
kid how's that 22 hours I know seriously
have a kid like you sort this [__] out
though from that but I'm not
recommending you do it but now I feel
like there needs to be some sort of way
of proving to people they were going to
employ you that you can [__] be on
time and be a responsible adult and and
I think from this interview I get that
you've you know where you [__] up
defin and you're sorry for that 100% but
I still don't know if you're like ready
mmm
do you know I'm saying and I don't fit
nice ways I wouldn't say I'm not just
hard to get much fitness when you ain't
got a team but it's all about this were
you in a cement yeah it's mental but
obviously I got caught listen this is my
last chance simple is that stats black
and white you this is my ring God's love
I before you're 30 May 30 I've been
missing her office so long now literally
I'm not spring chicken my legs lit she
you and all that stuff in I was feeling
little niggles I was getting nickels
here there I'm getting order in it you
know I'm here so your legs thing gonna
work forever I'm not rankings where he
snacks on broccoli Larry she I snack on
a snack back at normal snack oh yeah
and drink and fizzy g.o.d mom are you
scared or of being the 50 year old guy
in a pub see and I used to crawl a
Newcastle I've had that for so much
times and I'm rebuking I'm not having it
I'm not having it it's not gonna happen
no chance not gonna let happen but I for
about a lot of tense but I feel 50
imagine there's so much yeah
listen football career is a long it's
long but sure you gotta get all you can
have an invest
you gotta invest because after you don't
can't play football for everyone you
know I mean I feel like if you'd had a
good male role model from day one your
life would have been very different
because I tell you if there was a dad
there to put the fear of God in you to
make sure that you did [__] that you
should have been doing I think your life
would have been and many men and
and not just you like remember there was
one lad who I went to school with [__]
mate he was like Wayne Rooney on
steroids at 16 years old here and then
drugs Robin
it all just [__] common next thing I
know like it just never happened and
like hey I did mill get my models for
young men like who are likely to [__]
do the wrong thing you know it's so
important lucky for me is that I've done
well in games and people don't
understand that how is he so good in the
pitch but off the field is a [__] in
the mania mm-hmm but that's why I'm
established that's why normal wore up
did well in games established our team
might think let's take a chance on him
because he's you know he can play let's
see if he's actually flip that coin and
depending who are your clothes people
around you just because to me the RBF
wait forever for freedom no but like do
you have anyone who will be like
screaming at you to get out of bed in
the morning they've got a [__]
trainer view a few litchi will come to
my house and try grabbing out that
little ain't no I mean but this but
you've got to want to do this yourself
you've got to do yourself they can't
there's only so much they can do and say
like you know I mean they're like you've
been at a time where do you want it what
are you doing you should be training
every single day right in the gym like
you know I mean this is stressing me out
just even for yeah I know I'm like the
only thing I'm trying to think of like
what is the answer but I genuinely think
the only thing that's going to cut you
the way you need to pay is like fear
cause like for me the reason I think is
scary by the way like thirties [__]
scary more than me was fear of being
skinned like fear of having no money or
whatever and like and you guys in your
future you can't do good things and
invest what can you do you need to you
know I mean such true but you can make
another you can make a million pound
like you could you can make a lot of
money before your careers over and set
yourself up 100% unlike I don't know I
just think fears the only thing that is
gonna take that that inevitability like
this I feel like when we're young men
yeah and this is a good thing we change
careers a lot we make mistakes with [__]
or not
I've got lots of time and I can put this
right but I'm just so normal is there's
God knows yes if you haven't solid your
shell by 28 Jeremy there's no recovery
complacency that is a real issue in a
way because actually one thing that
strikes me is when we break one when you
read off a rap sheet or ever yeah you've
got all these things listed out again
we're sitting here and I still feel like
you're a good guy I still feel like you
didn't have a father figure as a kid you
had a mother who can play both roles
yeah but it does seem like you responded
well whenever you had because they say
in life you have two father figures
basically you have a real father and
then you have to leave that dad and go
away and find someone else who is your
your second measurement or or any of
those things it does sound that you
respond well to those kind of people
yeah and I'm not gonna say whom
patronize you because I don't think I've
got the experience that Brian has but it
does sound to me like you have a good
package there that someone could pick up
what are you what level are you aiming
for like who are you looking to come
along and say we want to shout out on
you is it Ligue 1 is Italy is it
championship and I know I can do in the
ego and I know I can play at the top
boys who ever charter teams in the you
mean that chance I'm gonna have to work
for that but I know that League One
Championship is definitely where I can
get chance what it's what teams are
saying now yeah I know they actually
sniffing around Nassau mm-hmm
Weis about what they offer do you know I
mean and it's not all about money but
get into this age you have to try and
invest you know I mean that I've wasted
so much time
you gotta get a decent deal done so you
can invest or you know I mean you've got
invested you might be able to invest
because what we don't last forever but I
don't have to do you know I mean do you
feel like you have you've gotten rid of
everyone who's not good for you or you
cuz it to me it's right absolutely
you're still in the process of changing
you know what wasn't built in a day in
its eyes it's slowly it's happening
slowly but do you see though so for
instance Brian and I block honest
conversations to meet each other
feedback about what we think the other
one is bad
I'm late a lot and I'm still working on
that I find that so hard
do they on time and I'm not patronizing
you so I can actually relate when you're
I don't find it hard to get in bed in
the same ways you do I'm going to place
another way but that is that doesn't
change in like one day nah it's Roman
building it is hard you got literally
that baby steps boss me I've got be
taking that she strides
yes strats Richie it there's no time not
waiting I'm alone so I was riding mmm I
gotta say I would no I'm not
I find it difficult to sit there and
hear us just talking to you I know and
you gotta just be open this is the row I
mean I want to say the things that the
people at home would want me to say my
feeling right now is you're talkin it
was cuz I I'm part of your story you're
part of my story now I came to feel
connected general employee see the story
in highlight video a message to Nell
Ranger just see how far you've come
pretty light yeah I wish you the [__]
best mate for the record and talk man I
really really really hope that if you do
get a chance that we don't hear he's
being fired from me never again that's
it I literally I know it sound bad he's
bad boy he sounds weird but it was for
lates my last no it wasn't no suffer die
yeah he's gonna crash the until his car
he's done this now he's late timekeeping
history yeah as opposed to your history
that's not that bad but it's still to
lose a job for being late as a focal
point you know it is bad D is bad it's
very bad because it rubs off on all the
other players they think why is this guy
coming at this time does he think this
is no more like I'm waking up it getting
in on time struggling
he comes in late and his thoughts on it
can be nickels away at people doesn't it
like they start to go always late yeah
exactly that's what I'm saying yeah you
don't want to but again a squat bar now
I'm too old to be being a bad day but it
also strikes me that actually I mean the
reason some people put up with you for
being late is because you the opposite
way bring something to the team when you
are there definitely they obviously have
a presence or about yeah you do i do you
know i mean so obviously you need that
you can't have any tom dick if i could
just say yes man in the team you need
someone with verbiage and i've got that
but it's like you eat it there's ways
you need to channel a book and put
positive in his one beyond time because
dankey pins major key who's a major I
admit well hopefully we'll do another
one of these when we're not awesome when
you see yeah I really miss a lot so I
really do me good look it and yeah let's
hope the club comes in failure and we'll
see you [__] fire and soon okay thank
you very enjoyed the podcast make sure
you hit the [__] like button
subscribe thanks for watching
see ya